un contratista está comprando baldosas
de piedra para un patio de piedra nuevo
cada baldosa cuesta tres dólares y
quiere gastar menos de mil dólares y
aquí está diciendo menos de ok y quiere
decir que el gasto debe ser menor que
1000 no puede ser menor o igual el
tamaño de cada baldosa es de un pie
cuadrado así que escribe una desigualdad
que representa el número de baldosas que
puede comprar con un límite de mil
dólares y después descubre qué tan
grande puede ser este patio de piedra
así que sea
x el número va a ser el número de
baldosas compradas de baldosas compradas
ok entonces con x vamos a relacionar el
número de baldosas que ha comprado este
este contratista y si queremos ver el
costo total pues simplemente tenemos que
multiplicar por 3 verdad porque cada una
de estas baldosas cuesta 3 dólares y el
costo total el costo total no debe pasar
es decir debe ser menor que 1000 muy
bien entonces para poder resolver esto
lo que necesitamos es dividir ambos
lados sobre 3 verdad dividimos ambos
lados sobre 3 como ya vimos en el vídeo
anterior y realmente como estamos
dividiendo entre algo positivo puedes
pensar que estamos multiplicando por un
tercio como es positivo en realidad no
tengo que cambiar el signo de la
desigualdad entonces esto se cancela y
tengo x menor que 1000 sobre 3 que son
333 y sobra un tercio
entonces el número de baldosas es menor
que 333 un tercio baldosas ok ahora bien
nos pregunta qué tan grande puede ser
este patio de piedra entonces el tamaño
el tamaño del patio tamaño del patio
como como cada baldosa mide un pie
cuadrado pues no puede pasar de esta
verdad que son 333 un tercio aquí vamos
a poner 10 cuadrados muy bien y hemos
terminado